en la mañana de este domingo en un
barrio Popular en las afueras del norte
de Río laibama la policía medio
ambiental brasileña tiene una misión
especial
en cuanto llegaron a este mercado los
miembros de la operación descubrieron
cientos de aves silvestres que estaban
siendo vendidas en estas pequeñas jaulas
a plena luz del día sin ningún documento
legal
solo tiene una jaula a quién le compró
esta
a un amigo
Cuánto le costó
cuando era bebé lo compré por 800 reales
junto con San Pablo ríos se ha
convertido en la capital del tráfico de
aves
la policía federal y medioambiental
decomisa más de 250.000 aves al año Este
mercado es un punto de venta estratégico
el equipo de Luis Felipe Bonifacio tuvo
que venir unos días antes de incógnito
en misión de reconocimiento un trabajo
que lleva mucho tiempo estos vendedores
se enfrentan apenas de solo entre seis
meses y un año de prisión mientras
esperan un fallo la mayoría son dejados
en libertad el mismo día
Lamentablemente en Brasil existe una
cultura de cría y comercio de aves
sabemos que no acabaremos con el tráfico
pero nos gustaría al menos acabar con
esta vitrina esta exhibición a la vista
de todos todos los domingos en este
barrio por ejemplo no podemos permitir
que eso suceda estamos poniendo todos
nuestros recursos en la lucha contra
este tráfico en total siete
contrabandistas detenidos
y 92 aves incautadas la mayoría de ellas
especies protegidas
antes de partir los agentes de la iguama
inspeccionan cada Rincón que están
buscando
buscamos posibles jaulas abandonadas con
animales porque muchas veces Los
Traficantes dejan las jaulas y huyen
de vuelta a la sede de la ibabama
comienza un delicado trabajo
al ser transportados en muy malas
condiciones nueve de cada 10 animales
mueren en el trayecto de la captura a la
compra
luchó tanto que se hizo daño tiene el
cráneo lleno de lesiones
el transporte que utilizan es totalmente
inadecuado sin agua y la mayoría de las
veces sin comida y en jaulas aún más
pequeñas que las que venden en el
mercado a veces las venden en tubos o
encerradas en botellas
la mayoría de estas especies estaban
destinadas al mercado nacional en Brasil
los concursos de canto de aves están de
moda tanto que hasta el presidente
saliente Jair bolsonaro visitó una feria
el pasado mes de octubre
durante su gobierno el presupuesto de la
policía medioambiental se vio
drásticamente reducido complicando la
labor de investigación y dejando el
campo libre a los traficantes los
suburbios de río uno de ellos accede a
hablar con nosotros sin Mostrar su
rostro Edu antes era narcotraficante
cree que vender aves es menos peligroso
tengo un loro y una guacamaya azul
en un mes puedo ganar unos 1200 euros
he vendido Tucanes antes pero el ave más
cara es la guacamaya azul
estos dos loros de especies protegidas
son los más vendidos en el mercado
informal del extranjero entre el animal
y el futuro propietario Edu es tan solo
un intermediario
hace 10 años un amigo me trajo un mico
negro siempre me han gustado los
animales y desde entonces descubrí el
mercado que hay para venderlos mi amigo
empezó a entregarme aves que caza en su
hábitat natural y yo las vendo ya he
vendido Tucanes pero el más rentable es
la guacamaya azul y por qué está
encadenada para que entienda que es
prisionera
para estas aves es un doble castigo
porque aunque consigan salvarse del
tráfico pocas consiguen ser liberadas en
la naturaleza
en el corazón de Río este es el difícil
trabajo del instituto vida libre esos
veterinarios se ocupan de las aves
recuperadas durante operaciones
policiales
comprobamos que el ave está en
condiciones de ser liberada
lo principal que comprobamos es si ha
sido domesticada Ese es el peligro no
puede estar demasiado domesticada
crochet seba y sus colegas reciben aquí
entre 3 y 4 aves al día
dale un poco de agua
Aquí Les enseña a hablar de nuevo
captura de pantalla
este pajarito es una especie en peligro
de extinción Este es el macho Y esta es
la hembra
hoy es un gran día va a liberar un Tico
tico una especie en peligro de extinción
muy apreciada por su canto
procede del tráfico Fue capturado
ilegalmente y va a ser liberado Y
devuelto a su hábitat natural creo que
es una apuesta que tenemos que hacer sí
por un lado la gente es cada vez más
consciente de que existe un problema de
tráfico en nuestro país pero por otro
Los Traficantes son cada vez más
ingeniosos y astutos a la hora de eludir
la ley en los controles policiales lo
que complica nuestro trabajo un rayo de
Esperanza el año pasado con su equipo
consiguió reintegrar en la naturaleza
1200 animales